what is up there reject nation happy
halloween weekend who do we got with us
we gotta i was just a ceiling fan
because you asked what's up there it's a
ceiling fan and all right and so it
begins tara erickson
has returned today we've gotten requests
for a long time a to have tara come back
b why haven't we been covering some
spooky vids like we have before well i'm
reserving them all for friday through
sunday because it's just the perfect
weekend for it why cause trick-or-treat
time people
so we're gonna kick off today with
another nukes top five video been a long
time tara i'm ready i'm gonna watch five
ghosts caught on cuckoo tv ah it's just
a tv
what is cctv closed captioning
television right oh is that really what
it stands for
yeah that's the first version of filming
you know it'll get better but guys since
tara drove 45 minutes to come here today
follow her on her youtube channel she
has a short film that's been popping off
called killjoy making the rounds oh real
killjoy it's a real killjoy craig
god
why am i even here you know i mean he
watched it he liked it he posted about
it on the community page yeah where'd
that video go oh i had to take it down
because it's in festivals
this is what happens when you join the
hollywood elite
example they
[Music]
okay
[Music]
five incidents of ghosts called on
surveillance video or cctv
paranormal creature calling camera
woman who recorded this video claimed
that she had been repeatedly startled
awake by strange unexplained noises in
her bedroom at night to try to determine
the cause of the strange sounds she
decided to set up a camera as she slept
this is what she found when she reviewed
the tape the next day
god i'm not ready
no what is that her or the kid the
couple have no pets but the video looks
almost like some sort of animal or
something no what is that
oh my god it's like a monkey next to the
woman's face oh nipple jumping down at a
strange backwards trajectory
[Music]
what the f
what holy moly that's a cat and they
blurted out or something everybody's
house blurry that's a baby that totally
looks like that's a baby there's a child
or someone trying to get up like either
a very small monkey or a child maybe
it's a ghost monkey huh i don't i don't
want it i can't explain that at all it
doesn't even look like a camera glitch
oh
but see how it's blurry on that side
yeah what it really looks like
oh god that's terrifying lady you need
to feed your baby or you need to move
that's not a ghost that's your child
he's hungry
shadow ghost hit by a car
a surveillance camera in the parking lot
of a malaysian hotel captures a strange
ghostly encounter
women are driving through the parking
lot when a mysterious shadow figure
darts in front of their car he ran over
the ghost slam on their brakes and get
out to investigate
but they find nothing
the mysterious shadow has vanished into
thin air
i mean it looks a little plant doesn't
it yeah it's like they had the camera up
in their room and they were like you
just drive and then i'll just like
insert yeah do some special effects they
also stop the car conveniently yeah
unless they stop the car because they
thought they saw something that's what
i'm saying i'm like it's either a ghost
and you didn't see it and you ran it
over or you're aware that you ran over
and goes
[Laughter]
jesus show you i think he hit that ghost
[Laughter]
uh i don't believe it yeah that looks
that looks fake to me the hotel room
ghost
now put this clip in another video a
long time ago but i feel like i'd be
remiss if i didn't include this incident
in a countdown of the creepiest ghost
clips caught on cctv sure so here it is
for those of you who haven't seen it
the security team at the wingate hotel
get called to one of the rooms due to
multiple reports by hotel guests of
someone screaming inside one of the
rooms
creepiest of all the room has not been
booked for the night so no one is
supposed to be inside
oh my god
screams go quiet as the security guard
enters
eventually we see a chilling disembodied
shape that seems to exit the room i saw
it the security guard reported look
right there furniture in the room has
been turned upside down
but
the room is empty
oh you're so right tara
gregory you know my name is
yeah i saw it
oh my god creepy that seems real because
how are you gonna have cameras up there
on a hotel on a health i can't that's
creepy i mean if he's a security guard
he hears a woman screaming i don't blame
him for going inside he's not just some
random dude passing through the hotel
yeah it's called your job buddy yeah
john the guy that the walkie was like
don't go in there just wait for the cops
to show up
just let her let her die and just
let her run
right let her suffer
this is a policeman this is why i could
never do security like you're absolutely
right let's wait around the cops right
you're my boss you got away from the car
he did go in he didn't hear screaming
and nothing was in there screaming on
that camera though i don't know there's
ways to amplify the audio let me talk to
my sound guy
that's right all these reactions have a
sound guy sure great just me just in the
volume he calls me tara i call him craig
yeah so my mom says sometimes i have an
eyelash in my eye that's
this is my life
you want to see me get it out is that
scary could we add this to the scary
video
i bet you could see it
this is called content
is it
i got it out disappearing woman
in bogota colombia a network news
station reports the appearance or rather
the disappearance of a woman captured on
two different surveillance cameras what
makes this video especially interesting
is that it was captured on two separate
cctv cameras at two different oh man
claim that the closest one is in a style
that was popular in the area over 100
years ago
[Music]
that is eerie
oh that is eerie two different what how
is she moving it could be just a skip
okay yeah then it moves like a
mysterious ominish and then it's just
gone oh wow that is strange i mean it
seems like it would be real from the
fact that it's on two separate cameras
yeah
oh that is suspicious
it's not very scary it's just weird okay
i'm like wait what happened to her but
she's pretty transparent look look at
that look how transparent she is see
maybe it's an effect
there are some bored-ass security guards
out there i'm saying
real ghosts why are we looking for her
what's her name we're trying to find a
girl with blue shirt and and black
slacks but it's on two different cameras
i'm sure some of these have been
debunked already this video is a tad bit
old
but i choose to believe it's real okay
i believe in ghosts do you believe in
code yes yeah i absolutely believe in
ghosts and the good and the good ghosts
like the last one was a good ghost ghost
who like saved children from burning
buildings you know good ghosts good
ghosts mexico city intersection ghost
on september 18th at 2 20 a.m in the
morning cctv cameras covering a busy
intersection in mexico city seemed to
capture what appears to be the ghost of
a young girl appearing in the middle of
a busy intersection
what where right there the circle the
water hotel video what truly makes this
footage interesting is that the supposed
apparition is caught from multiple
angles and can be seen from three
different cctv cameras at the exact same
time
oh
damn whoa
[Music]
wow
that is gnarly
good
see how they didn't stop because it was
a real ghost yeah only the camera shelly
just drive through the coast we're not
going through this again
we're already
jetted to mexico to get away from the
first coast
shelly i don't have time for jail not
this year you can't keep running over a
ghost show
shelley is obsessed with killing kelly
is a damn murderer
we hate shelly that was really eerie but
okay i guess the question is though is
i mean people are faking that if people
are faking that how how are they faking
it i mean other than i i know you could
do the effects but were they like
talking to their security buddy friends
and like hey can i get access to this
footage just way to hack the footage
just to make this viral video would
people go that far are there people who
go that far i okay here's how i think
it's this easy you find a light pole and
you put a gopro and you're like block
blunk blunk and then you're like graphic
oh graphic and then add the numbers and
stuff
yeah because that's easy i mean the
numbers you can get from anywhere all
right well this whole video is a lie and
so is he a lie
no i'm not he's not even here that's
what makes it so spooky i've been
sitting here with a ghost all right let
me talk to my effects guy did i have
some transparent effects yeah that's
good blurry out or we can do a cheap
man's jump cut
no just stay frozen oh got it take two
or we could do a cheap man's jump cut
that didn't work all right guys well
tara's back here thank you tara for
being here
go check out her where can people what
should they look out for their horror
stuff i mean
just look up my name tara erickson don't
forget it t-a-r-a
e-r-i-c-k-s-o-n at your short film yeah
my short film a real killjoy come out
it's in festivals but then also go to my
youtube channel and subscribe
do it guys thank you so much for being
here happy halloween
you